I believe that education is a public  ride and I think that's now in more  danger than ever before education is  where our society reproduces itself  international students right now have to  pay for the NHS and will be being kicked  out of the country after we graduate  education is a high note apparently my  family believe that education is a  social good that benefits the whole of  society and should be treated as such  for education is a thing that's like  beneficial for the economy the  government is deciding now on stuff  that's going to affect the porous  earners hardest education is not a  commodity and the government shouldn't  be pricing people out of going to  university they're also thinking of even  worse things things that are  unimaginable to us now with our  university system